[Musique]
richard bartel herry bonjour bonjour
monsieur carwash vous vous étiez déjà
présenté face aux électrices et
électeurs de la trinité il y a près de
six ans vous renouveler l'expérience
pour 2020 dans un autre contexte
évidemment ce ne sera pas d'ailleurs
face aux même merde sortant alors
richard bartel riz qu est ce qui vous
laisse penser que cette fois cela
pourrait être couronnée de succès eh
bien je dis bonjour également aux
trinitéenne et autres i need rien et si
je suis candidat à cette élection c'est
pense que nous avons rendu visite un
maximum de trinité hier nous avons fait
appel aux trinité ils nous ont entendus
et maintenant nous écoutons les
trinitéens et c'est parce que nous les
écoutons que nous serons candidats avec
mon groupe unité trinitéenne à
l'élection à l'élection municipale de
tri de trinité très bien si vous étiez
élu avec vos colistiers donc quel
dossier est estimée auriez-vous comme le
plus urgent
donc du point de vue de la municipalité
compte oui alors le il ya beaucoup de
dossiers urgents à trinité tous les
dossiers sont pratiquement des dossiers
et aux gens il faut savoir que notre
projet c'est un projet qui basé sur
l'intérêt du trinitéen l'humain au
centre de nos préoccupations
c'est à dire que c'est un projet qui a
une philosophie où nous allons tout
faire pour que le trinitéen et plus de
confort plus de cadre de vie et que
également trinité soient développés
qu'aux trinité est un développement qui
sont en développement qui aille dans le
sens si dans l'intérêt de simples de sa
population
donc ce qu'il faut bien savoir c'est que
les contacts que nous avons eus depuis
quelques mois et même je peux dire même
de trois ans avec les trinitéens nous
sommes passés dans plusieurs cars
entiers et les revendications des
habitants de ces quartiers sont toujours
les mêmes
les gens ne vous demande pas grand chose
ils vous demandent que les routes soit
le revêtement de la route soit bien fait
ils vous demandent que leurs badges sur
les accotements soit coupé il vous
demande qu'il y ait de l'éclairage et en
plus les jeunes par contre vous demandez
une chose il vous demande qu'il y ait la
possibilité d'avoir accès au numérique
sur l'e40 chili à des quartiers qui sont
très loin de ça et par conséquent ils
nous demandent que les quartiers soient
équipés en espace numérique
donc voila un petit peu une priorité et
puis le personnel municipal pour à une
attention particulière moi j'estime que
mes années page et or d'habitation mères
et de mères mais à doit savoir que son
personnel à une hiérarchie qui doit unir
en chine qui responsable du personnel et
qui par conséquent lui donne des ordres
et qui exécute les ordres de la
hiérarchie
moi je veux pas être meilleur qui sera
sur le dos du personnellement je crois
que le personnel municipal et dans une
très grande souffrance
actuellement et par conséquent nous
allons tout faire pour que ce personnel
deux concerts puisse travailler avec
l'équipe municipale les les conseils
municipaux les adjoints est également le
maire nous allons faire en sorte qu'il y
ait une espèce des terres activités
entre le personnel municipal et l'équipe
municipale alors le shabbat et derry
vous a fait un peu de vent c'est ma ma
troisième question donc je vais je vais
finalement l'éluder puisque nous avait
dit un petit peu selon vous quelles sont
les principales préoccupations de
l'électorat trinitéen par contre il ya
un contexte particulier pour cette
municipale à la trinité la de mars
prochain
c'est que on aura une rivalité interne
un petit peu à la famille socialiste si
vous voulez si on veut puisque le maire
sortant frédéric duval n'est plus à la
fsm et il y aura une candidate soutenue
par la fédération socialiste de la
martinique vos richard barthélémy vous
êtes maintenant à payer s'il me semble
bien c'est ça non je n'ai pas à payer
l'addition
voilà vous êtes soutenu je vais
clarifier ça va tout de suite vu que je
suis un candidat qui est g
l'investiture de unité trinitéenne
puisque le 1er février 2019
on a fait appel à candidature dans mon
groupe une sérénité on était environ une
quarantaine de personnes on a fait appel
à candidatures n'y en a pas eu donc j'ai
levé mon doigt et je me suis porté
candidat à cette élection municipale et
autres unités et par conséquent j'ai été
élu par mon groupe maintenant et je
termine message et le soutien de pays où
le parti politique est vraiment c'est un
honneur pour moi d'être soutenu par un
parti politique qui est coprésidé vous
êtes toujours mieux entendu mme je ne
suis plus militant du mime
tout simplement parce qu'on m'a fait
comprendre que je dors plus ma place non
ma faim quand vous avez le soutien de
pays amis je n'avais pas le soutien du
mime
alors là je ne sais pas si je le
soutiens du mémo leur demande leur
soutien du maire vous allez leur poser
la question par contre ce que je sais
c'est que personnellement je suis prêt à
accepter les soutiens donc ils viennent
je peux pas refuser le soutien de celui
ci ou de celui merci richard batellerie
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
c'est moi qui vous remercie
[Musique]